should we set up the Easter Egg lights
welcome to quality content with Justine
and Jenna well you're gonna have an egg
hunt today for our dog and what's gonna
happens I don't think he's gonna be so
interested in the treats that are inside
so I think green - totally covered in
peanut butter we're also going to put a
little dog harness on him another
problem is he doesn't like when he has a
harness on we did this to me once before
this is the insta 360 camera so this is
basically going to get a 360 view of
everything in the Maddy is he oh my gosh
it's probably not gonna move there's me
standing there did we put the stick on
him last no he did not have him stick on
him okay I saw probably she could stick
off cuz that might seem a little
aggressive like he's gonna be like
Bernie fell over when he was a baby we
put his harness on he just humbled I'm
Maddie
it is not gonna do that he's gonna look
like those like Google cars at Lockhart
like throw driver homes he is oh my gosh
Maddie Google car okay alright let's get
this started
[Music]
he's not gonna be able to open them he's
too gentle
Jeff sester gentleman couldn't open it
my mom always plays this game with him I
forgot to bring over the Easter Egg
basket I have 100 chutes that's a big
one
what's your foot in the golden one money
he's a dog he has money he's had like
two sponsored posts sure - guys she
needs more he doesn't more we're gonna
pay for himself he has expensive food
and expensive tastes
I'm sorry put one in there he's gonna
absolutely hate this I don't even know
okay I didn't see oh no
well he's gonna be able to see us
there's a reflection he's gonna heal us
yes okay we've got our eggs in here oh I
forgot the basket I think that the key
thing that we're gonna do here is we
need to cover the hood peanut butter
because he's not gonna be that
interested he's so gentle I feel like
that's wrong what's wrong well I don't
know if any of people pee over there on
the inside so he cracks it open
let's do both all right okay you'll see
this right this is an Easter egg hunt
for Maddie we just put it on the outside
she's really messy you already have a
fly problem like tie your eyes like
peanut butter find out won't we go stick
him in that swarm I shall hide did you
know it's warm in Los Angeles today it's
really warm you're right I'm wearing ugg
boots I think you think I'll find it
I'll repeat on it well he's cheating
he's cheating Maddie no peeking on the
egg hunt I don't know what you're
thinking I know what you're thinking
putting it on the inside you can still
smell it and that we have to break it
open
you're just making a mess I am making a
mess
think he's gonna find it yeah well it's
a hunt if you can't find this I think
you know he probably is that puke that's
the peanut butter from the first date
hunt because we had to reshoot this so
this is a cuz I okay yep they don't talk
about it Marshall I had this may be
right here they actually hide it okay
what is look in there he's not gonna
find it I've tried the Ford psychos day
look I've never tried that before this
is the first time uh are we go
seriously what's that smell I don't know
it's probably the bodies that I have not
hidden anywhere Roger came with the
house okay
the eggs are hidden okay thanks or
hidden now we have to put the harness on
Maddie oh I don't think he's gonna like
this very much okay let's wait let me
put oh let me okay well we gotta get the
harness on Maddie oh there we go okay
you can't hunt eggs without yeah putting
this on
hold on a second leg yep yeah come on
boy
you lift that back leg up okay back leg
up okay good boy is it touching his his
his undercarriage on his your
undercarriage his special carriage oh
yeah Wow just tie this together so this
is the insta 360 1x camera it's one of
my favorite cameras it's great because
it does shoot 360 and we've got 20
minutes left on those card Madi so let
the games begin
[Applause]
but you were having so much fun when the
camera wasn't on you doing ease so maybe
like here come on yeah boy the great
step do you mean a step okay here you go
come on you can get boosted there you go
wow this is pathetic wow this is
something
get him a knee
you look cool okay
[Music]
Wow
he's hunting this is the most uneventful
egg hunt that I've ever witnessed in my
life like he's Maddie can you look for
the eggs like they're right here look
look Oh peanut butters on that egg
you got a lick so I guess maybe we take
the harness off of him cuz he's not he
took like 20 steps he did he did
something much better than they would
have never done this before
who would've ever had this before then
he would have done this much better this
time
yeah you guys haven't got the joke right
now had a corrupted SD card so I lost
all the footage that we shot so this is
a good night we're doing yeah we were
much quicker than what this harness on
the first time really did
okay that's off of them get it knock it
off you so you got
so there's an AVO here oh I'm so proud
oh good he's performing yeah he hunted
one he's hunted oh my god my gosh she's
laying down oh my gosh he's hunting this
is really great it feels a little less
exciting than I thought it was gonna be
I thought he was gonna be running all
over you really just pumped his tails
wagging he's having fun it's just very
slow fun he's really getting that pant
butter out of there he's maybe still
thirsty after that I know so hot why are
you walking so slow do you think that's
what I say do you want a hike I don't
need it okay Maddie ready sit there you
go oh look at that sad egg hunt it's so
pathetic good boy yeah you know it looks
like he hatched one don't do that he's
trying to get that peanut but now he has
peanut butter his tail he doesn't have
hands well he has four legs we can use
them well that's something that we did
if you guys want to follow me on
instagram his instagram is DJ mini matt
that's because he's a DJ like he
actually can be jay i'm also on
instagram where is his DJ setup it
doesn't matter he's a professional egg
hunter no definitely not
but the gears are watching I hope you
guys have an awesome Easter if you guys
enjoyed this video let us know if you
didn't enjoy it just give it a like for
the sake of Maddy being a sweet boy look
at him he has peanut butter Olaf lips
maybe we can have an Easter egg hunt job
we usually do our traditional he's our
accessory hunts but if you guys remember
if you've been around for a long time
like we used to do them all the time
every year they weren't in the one year
I had a drone I was actually doing some
recon previous to starting the egg hunts
that I couldn't know where they were I
think maybe if we just like left him
alone to do his own thing like he'd be
like yeah
for that one I think he's having fun I
think he needs water
he's RC yeah he's thirsty okay joy drink
thank you for watching we didn't do this
twice or anything no first the first
time first raha hai my nails are Chloe
different color are that's incredible
first try we'll see you guys in the next
video happy Easter and go say hi to
Maddie on Instagram I got she'll say
magenta - oh I typed back to you he
types back he does with his little paw
bye bye your name Jill Maddie you are an
angel
he has peanut butter over for his lips
what a hog hey Maddie we have 29 minutes
on our SD card okay and dove you know
are you ready yep there's a tree
oh you at this tree might have to take
it off this is super sad
all right here if you wanna go for a run
you know just slow walk go ahead let's
make a movie Bonnie I'm good break his
trust
a little Horace is too loose hey Steve
Joelle harness is too loose what's going
on your buster oh you can get it boy
yes
really really just thought this was
gonna be you could take it off with him
you might think he might know now I'm
covered in pee everywhere
[Music]